ASSEMBLYMEMBER FLORA NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL. WE ARE
CURRY ARAMBULA. BAUER-KAHAN
BERMAN BIGELOW BLOOM
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA BRO BURKE
CALDERON CARRILLO CERVANTES
CHAU CHEN DAVID CHIU CHOI
KANSEN CHU COOLEY COOPER
CUNNINGHAM DALLY DALY DEEP.
EGGMAN FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ GRAY
GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN JONESSAWYER KALRA KAMLAGER KILEY
LACKEY LEVINE LIMON LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS RAMOS THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO SMITH. STONE TING
VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER WICKS WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT IN THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK
THAT OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND IN
THE GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR
THE PRAYER. TODAY'S PRAYER WILL
BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN THE REVEREND PETTY
OSHA ERNEST. PLEASE JOIN ME IN
A MOMENT OF REFLECTION. THERE
IS A RULE THAT WE FOLLOW
WHENEVER TRAVELING IT IS THIS.
TRY NOT TO COMPARE WHERE WE ARE
VISITING WITH WHERE WE ARE FROM.
IN NOT COMPARING WE ALLOW
OURSELVES TO SIMPLY EXPERIENCE
IN ENJOY EACH PLACE JUST AS IT
IS. IN TRAVELING WITH COMPARING
WE BECOME OPEN TO THE UNIQUE
DIFFERENCES THAT MAKE EACH
PLACE SPECIAL. ON MONDAY WE
RETURN FROM FAIRBANKS ALASKA
THIS WAS OUR FIRST ATTEMPT TO
VIEW THE AURORA BOREALIS
ALTHOUGH CONDITIONS WERE NOT
CONDUCIVE WE THOROUGHLY ENJOYED
OUR FOUR DAYS IN FAIRBANKS. IT
WAS EXHILARATING TO WAKE UP TO
A DAY THAT WAS MINUS THIRTY ONE
DEGREES. TO VIEW A WORLD I
SCULPTING COMPETITION TO EACH
KING CRAB UNTIL WE COULD EAT NO
MORE AND TO BE PULLED ON THIS
LEAD THROUGH THE SNOW BY A TEAM
OF TEN DOGS. IN NOT COMPARING
WE ALLOWED OURSELVES TO
EXPERIENCE IN ENJOY FAIRBANKS
JUST AS IT IS. AND IN LOOKING
BACK. WE FEEL ONLY GRATEFUL.
FOR OUR ENTIRE TRIP HAS NOW
BECOME A VERY SPECIAL MEMORY.
NOW MOMMY NOW WITH THE WITH
KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE BEYOND
WORDS. THANK YOU REVEREND WE
ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE MISTER
GRACE. PLEASE JOIN IN THE
PLEDGE. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO.
IS A LITTLE. THANK YOU YOU MAY
BE SEATED. READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY
CHAMBER SACRAMENTO THURSDAY
FEBRUARY TWENTY SEVENTH TWENTY
TWENTY THE ASSEMBLY MET AT NINE
AM ON BOTH KEVIN MULLIN SPEAKER
PRO TEM ASSEMBLY PRESIDING SHE
CLICKS YOU PARKER AT THE DESK
READING CLICK KATHLEEN AND
LOUIS READINGTHE REBELS CALLED
IT'S ONLY MEMBER BAUER CAN MOVE
CALL THE ASSEMBLY MOTION CARRY
TIME IN A NINE AM. THIS THE
SERGEANTS AND MR FLORA SECONDS
THAT THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH. PRESENTATIONS
AND PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED. REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE. THERE
ARE NONE. MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR
THE DAY. PERSONAL BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHRISTY SMITH
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER JORDAN
CUNNINGHAM. FOR ILLNESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS FRAZIER. AND
GRAY. AND FOR MATERNITY LEAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SABRINA
CERVANTES. MR BONTA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTION SIR. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN A TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS MATHIS IRWIN AND EGGMAN
TO HAVE GUESTS AND
PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE FLOOR.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER I FOR THE REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE TO ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER
HOLDEN. AND CHAO TO SPEAK ON
AND ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY
TODAY. AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER. WE
MEMBERS WE HAVE SPECIAL GUEST
WITH US IN THE ASSEMBLY TODAY.
YEAH. MR A FLORA YOU HAVE
GUESTS WITH US MEMBERS. PLEASE
GIVE ATTENTION TO MISTER FLORA.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING A CONSTITUENT OF MINE
A FELLOW RIP AND RESIDENT FROM
THE GREAT WITH TOP PROBLEMS OF
RIBBON MIKE IS HERE TO DAY
AFTER BEING RECOGNIZED BY THE
CALIFORNIA POULTRY FEDERATION
AS OUR ALLIED. OF THE YEAR MIKE
MORE THAN TWENTY YEARS IN THE
INDUSTRY WAS CHOSEN FOR ITS
EXCEPTIONAL SERVICE AND
CONTRIBUTION. JOIN ME IN WHAT
MR HOGAN WITH PROCEDURE
SERVICER. PLEASE STAND. AND MS
RAMOS. YOU HAVE GUESTS IN THE
CHAMBER TODAY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS. I AM SO PROUD
TODAY TO WELCOME. TO THE
CAPITAL A GROUP OF SOME OF THE
BRIGHTEST YOUNG PEOPLE FROM MY
DISTRICT TO REPRESENT THE HIGH
SCHOOLS IN THE FORTY SEVEN
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THEY'RE PART
OF THE YOUNG LEGISLATORS
PROGRAM. THESE THIRTY FOUR
STUDENTS REPRESENTS THE CITIES
OF DECEMBER TO BE NO. FONTANA
RIALTO BLOOMINGTON MUST SCORE
COLTON AND GRAND TOURISTS.
THEY'VE BEEN TOURING THE
CAPITAL AND MEETING WITH STAFF
AND MEMBERS TO LEARN MORE ABOUT
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS LET
LEGISLATIVE PURPOSE AND HOW
GOVERNMENT WORKS. AFTER NINE
MONTHS F WORKING DILIGENTLY
UNDERSTANDING OUR STATE
GOVERNMENT THESE REALLY YOUNG
LEGISLATORS HAVE LEARNED A
VARIETY OF SKILLS TO HELP THEM
BECOME THE LEADERS OF TOMORROW.
SO MEMBER PLEASE HELP ME IN
WELCOMING THE YOUNG LEGISLATORS
OF EIGHTY. AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FROM MY DESK FOR
YOUR SPECIAL PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER IN
MEMBERS WAS MY GREAT PRIVILEGE
TO RECOGNIZE THE VETERANS OF
FOREIGN WAR ON THEIR HUNDRED
YEAR ANNIVERSARY- WITH US TODAY
THE GALLERY IS- SEVERAL MEMBERS
OF THE VFW AND WE'RE HERE WITH
ME IS COMMANDER GOOSE NECK-
SOME OF THE VFW DEPARTMENT
GOALS ARE TO MENTOR NEW AND
YOUNGER MEMBERS. TO HAVE THEM
THE MORNING. IN THE VETERANS
ORGANIZATIONS TO PROVIDE BETTER
COMMUNICATION TO MEMBERS. TO
SERVE OUR VETERANS AND OUR
COMMUNITY. THEY HAVE SEVERAL
ACCOMPLISHMENTS OVER THE LAST.
OF YEARS DOING YOU SCHOLARSHIP
PROGRAMS VOICE OF DEMOCRACY
PATRIOTS FANS SCOUTS OF THE
YEAR TEACHERS OF THE YEAR LAST
YEAR'S NATIONAL MIDDLE SCHOOL
TEACHER OF THE YEAR WAS FROM
CALIFORNIA IT WAS RECOGNIZED BY
THE VFW. LAW ENFORCEMENT OF THE
YEAR EMERGENCY MEDICAL
TECHNICIAN OF THE YEAR
FIREFIGHTER THE VETERANS OF
FOREIGN WARS SERVICE OFFICERS
ASSISTED VETERANS AND RECEIVING.
THIRTY MILLION 900-407-0006
HUNDRED FORTY FOUR DOLLARS AND
COMPENSATION. LAST YEAR SO FAR
THIS ADMINISTRATIVE YEAR VFW
MEMBERS HAVE DONATED FOUR
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THOUSAND
TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY FOUR
DOLLARS AND SEVENTY FIVE CENTS
IN VOLUNTEERED. OVER. SEVENTY
FOUR THOUSAND HOURS MEMBERS.
I'M A LIFELONG MEMBER OF THE
VFW IT'S JUST A GREAT HONOR TO
RECOGNIZE THEM THE THINGS THAT
THEY DO- VFW ASSISTED ME WITH
MY COLLEGE EDUCATION. AND I'M
JUST EXTREMELY EXCITED AND
HAPPY TO HAVE COMMANDER COMES
HERE WITH US PLEASE WELCOME
THEM BEFORE.
MEMBERS WE HAVE
ADDITIONAL GUEST WITH US.
DOCTOR EGGMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK FOR
YOUR GUESTS INTRODUCTION THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS TODAY UP IN THE GALLERY
I HAVE OF MY DISTRICT ATTORNEY
TORY RIVER SALAZAR FIRST WOMAN
DA OF SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY ONE OF
THE BEST THE AGE IN THE STATE
AND ALSO WITH HER IS ONE OF MY
FORMER STUDENTS ON HELL ARE YOU
ARE YOU FROM TWO THOUSAND AND
TEN. YOU'RE STILL DOING GOOD
WORK- THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND- A
BIG ASSEMBLY WELCOME.
MEMBERS
WE ARE MOVING TO BUSINESS ON
THE DAILY FILE. ON
RECONSIDERATION FILE ITEMS ONE
TWO AND THREE ARE TO BE
CONTINUED. WE ARE ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING. MEMBERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
THE TAKE UP FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIVE. FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE. ON
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING IS ACR
ONE SEVENTY SEVEN BY MISTER
GRAYSON. YEAH THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE SEVENTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON WELL TO
DO FAMILY JUSTICE CENTERS
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION TO MISTER GRAYSON
RESTORATION YOUR RECOGNIZE
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE TODAY TO
INTRODUCE A C. R. ONE SEVENTY
SEVEN WHICH WOULD DECLARE MARCH
FIFTH AS FAMILY JUSTICE CENTER
DAY IN CALIFORNIA. FAMILY
JUSTICE CENTERS ARE
COMPREHENSIVE MULTI AGENCY
CENTERS THAT PROVIDE A ONE STOP
SHOP OF SUPPORT SERVICES TO
VICTIMS OF INTERPERSONAL
VIOLENCE INCLUDING INTIMATE
PARTNER VIOLENCE SEXUAL ASSAULT
CHILD ABUSE OF ELDERLY ABUSE
AND HUMAN TRAFFICKING DURING.
HAPPEN WE STOPPED. I WORK WITH
VICTIMS OF INTERPERSONAL
VIOLENCE AND WITNESSED FIRST
HAND THE LACK OF STREAMLINED
SERVICES AVAILABLE FOR VICTIMS
AND THE CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT OF
TRAUMA THAT THEY FACED JUST
TRYING TO GET HELP. AS A RESULT
OF THIS EXPERIENCE I CO FOUNDED
THE CENTRAL COUNT CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY FAMILY JUSTICE CENTER
AND A BIG SHOT UP TO US TO SEND
KIM FOR ALL HER HELP. AND WITH
THAT CALIFORNIA IS A NATIONAL
LEADER IN COLLABORATIVE
APPROACH ISN'T EVEN DOMESTIC
SEXUAL VIOLENCE SURVIVORS AND
THEIR CHILDREN. THERE ARE NOW
TWENTY FOUR THANKS TO ALL OF
YOUR HELP A COUPLE YEARS AGO
THERE ARE NOW TWENTY FOUR OPEN
AND ARE GETTING FAMILY JUSTICE
CENTERS YES THIS INCLUDING.
THAT OPENED LAST MONTH. DESPITE
THIS PROGRESS THE MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES DO NOT HAVE
A FAMILY JUSTICE CENTER. I AM
COMMITTED TO MAKING SURE EVERY
SURVIVOR HAS ACCESS TO SUPPORT
AND THE CARE THAT THEY NEED TO
BREAK THE CYCLE OF ABUSE AND
VIOLENCE FRIENDS AND
COLLEAGUES. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION AND A RECOGNITION OF
THE LIFESAVING AND HOPE GIVING
THE WORK OF THIS INCREDIBLE
ORGANIZATION AND WHAT THEY
PROVIDE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER GRAYSON SEEING NO
OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE RESOLUTION.
MR GRAYSON WOULD YOU LIKE CO
AUTHORS PLEASE THANK YOU MISTER
RACES REQUESTED THAT THE FIRST
ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS
MEMBERS CLARK LOCAL THE ROLE.
AMHERST THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS. FIND
YOUR DESK MEMBERS THIS IS FOR
CO AUTHORS. THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION. THE
CLERK WELL. CLOSE ROLE THERE
ARE SIXTY EIGHT CO AUTHORS
ADDED IN WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED MISTER GRAYSON
BACKSTREET YOU FOR YOUR SPECIAL
GUEST INTRODUCTION. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER COLLEAGUES I DO
RISE AGAIN TO RECOGNIZE A FEW
GUESTS FROM THE FAMILY JUSTICE
CENTER COMMUNITY. INCLUDING
CASES WHERE THE PRESIDENT AND
CO FOUNDER OF THE ALLIANCE OF
HOPE AND THE VISIONARY BEHIND
THE FIRST FAMILY JUSTICE CENTER
IN SAN DIEGO. ALEX PLEASE TAKE
A MOMENT TO JOIN. IN WELCOMING
THEM TO CALIFORNIA SO. PLEASE
STAND IF YOU WILL. MEMBERS
MOVING BACK IN THE FILE THE
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR. THIS IS
A C. R. ONE FIFTY SEVEN BY MISS
WALDRON THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE FIFTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WALDRON AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO CALIFORNIA ARBOR
DAY. MISS WALDRON YOUR
RECOGNIZE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. I RISE AS
THE AUTHOR OF THIS IMPORTANT
RESOLUTION. TO RECOGNIZE MARCH
SEVENTH. TWENTY TWENTY AS
CALIFORNIA ARBOR DAY AND
ENCOURAGE CALIFORNIANS TO JOIN
THE CELEBRATION WITH TREE
PLANTING AND COMMUNITY
BEAUTIFICATION PROJECT. J.
STERLING MORTON PROPOSE THE
FIRST ARBOR DAY IN EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY TWO TO LEARN NEBRASKA
STATE BOARD OF AGRICULTURE.
SINCE THEN THE HOLIDAY HAS
EXPANDED ACROSS THE U. S. AND
OVERSEAS. THE NEED FOR OUR
BIRTHDAY AND COMMUNITY
BEAUTIFICATION IS EVIDENT
NATION WIDE A STUDY PERFORMED
BY THE US FOREST SERVICE
INDICATES THAT THE NATIONAL
URBAN COMMUNITY TREE LOS. IS
AROUND A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
FIVE THOUSAND ACRES OR THIRTY
SIX MILLION TREES EVERY YEAR.
THIS LOSS PREVENTS
ENVIRONMENTAL AESTHETIC AND
FINANCIAL HARDSHIP AND THIS
PORTION DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTS DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. THE BENEFITS OF
TREE PROJECTS INCLUDE REDUCING
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS ENERGY
CONSUMPTION AND AIR POLLUTION
WHILE BOOSTING CARBON
SEQUESTRATION WHILE ADDING
AMAZING BEAUTY TO OUR LIVES. AS
CALIFORNIA HOLDS ITSELF OUT AS
A NATIONAL LEADER ON CLIMATE
PROTECTIONS AND EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS IT IS IMPERATIVE
THAT WE RECOGNIZE THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF TREES AND THEIR
ROLE IN URBAN COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE STATE. I AM PROUD TO
HAVE THE SUPPORT OF CALIFORNIA
RELIEVE THE CALIFORNIA URBAN
FOREST COUNCIL AND THREE PEOPLE
WHO CEO MY FRIEND AND FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CINDY MANTEGNA'S
HAS BEEN A LIFELONG CHAMPION OF
URBAN FAR AS- J. STERLING
MORTON ONE STATED. ARBOR DAY IS
NOT LIKE OTHER HOLIDAYS EACH OF
THOSE REPOSE IS ON THE PAST
WELL ARBOR DAY PROPOSED
PROPOSES FOR THE FUTURE. I
RESPECTFULLY URGE AN AYE VOTE
AND ASK FOR THE FIRST ROLE TO
BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS. THANK
YOU MISS WALDRON SEEING NO
OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON ACR ONE FIFTY
SEVEN. THE OTHERS ASSN THE
PERSONAL BE ABLE OF CO AUTHORS
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. THIS
IS FOR CO AUTHORS THIS IS FOR
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS. CO
AUTHORS AND ACR ONE FIFTY SEVEN.
CLERK WILL CLOSER ALL THERE ARE
SIXTY SEVEN CO AUTHORS ADDED
AND WITHOUT OBJECTION. WE MAY
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE AC ARE
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY THE AYES HAVE
IT THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED
MOVING TO SENATE THIRD READING.
PASS A RETAIN A FILE ITEM SIX
FILE ITEM SEVEN. IS SB FIVE
EIGHTY EIGHT FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS CLERK WILL READ WITH
AMENDMENTS SENATE BILL FIVE
EIGHTY EIGHT WITH AMENDMENTS BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- WHEN- WHEN ON
THE AMENDMENTS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE PRESENTS AUTHOR
AMENDMENTS TO SB FIVE EIGHTY
EIGHT BY SENATOR ARCH OF THESE
AMENDMENTS ADDRESS CONCERNS
BROUGHT FORWARD BY STATE
AGENCIES REGARDING THEIR
ABILITY TO PURCHASE PENALTIES
AND RIVER FUNDS. AFTER PRIME
CONTRACTORS HAVE BEEN PAID
THROUGH THE DISABLED VETERAN
BUSINESS ENTERPRISE PROGRAM I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I'VE A-
THANK YOU MISTER WHEN. SEEN NO
DISCUSSION ON THE AMENDMENTS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOTE VOICE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY THE
AYES HAVE IT THE MEMBERS AE
ADOPTED THE BILLS OUT OF PRINT
AND BACK. ON FILE. MEMBERS I
WOULD LIKE TO MOVE BACK TO
GUEST INTRODUCTIONS. DOCTOR
CHAN I BELIEVE YOU HAVE SOME
GAS. I'M GOING TO RECOGNIZE.
DOCTOR PHILLIP CHEN. MISTER
SPEAKER THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME AND THE POINT OF
PRIVILEGE I WANT TO WELCOME
CELEBRANTS CHRISTIAN SCHOOL TO
THE CAPITAL SACRAMENTO THERE
ARE FOURTH GRADERS COMING FROM.
IN MY DISTRICT ROWLAND HEIGHTS
AND I REMEMBER MY FIRST TIME
COMING TO THE CAPITAL IT WAS A
LITTLE BIT MY MISTAKE WAS IN
WASHINGTON AND PERHAPS SOME OF
THESE PEOPLE WILL BE INSPIRED
AND MOTIVATED TO RUN FOR OFFICE
ONE DAY- WITHOUT FURTHER ADO
LET'S WELCOME SOUTH PLANTS
CHRISTIAN SCHOOL. FROM RELIANCE.
MEMBERS WE WILL NOW MOVE TO THE
SECOND A CONSENT CALENDAR.
MEMBERS MAY I HAVE YOUR
ATTENTION. THERE IS A
RESOLUTION ON TODAY'S CALENDAR
CONSENT CALENDAR. BEFORE WE
VOTE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ITSELF WE WILL FIRST TAKE UP
THE RESOLUTION THAT IS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FOR THE
PURPOSE OF ADDING CO AUTHORS
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE
ONE ROLL CALL VOTE AND ALLOW
ANY MEMBER TO ADD ON AS A CO
AUTHOR TO THE RESOLUTION. THE
CLERK WILL READ THE RESOLUTIONS
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR. SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION EIGHTY
THREE BY SENATOR DODD RELATIVE
TO EATING DISORDERS AWARENESS
WEEK. THE CLERK WILL NOW OVER
THE ROLE TO ALLOW ANY MEMBER TO
ADD ON AS A CO AUTHOR TO THE
RESOLUTION CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION ON CONSENT THIS
IS FOR CO AUTHORS. THIS VOTE IS
FOR CO AUTHORS. MEMBERS IF YOU
WISH TO ADD YOUR NAME IS A CO
AUTHOR OF THE RESOLUTION SIGNED.
PLEASE VOTE NOW. THE CLERK WELL
CLOSER ALL THERE ARE SEVENTY CO
AUTHORS ADDED THE CLERK WILL
APPLY THAT PH<c.cyan>O THE</c>
RESOLUTION THAT IS ON TODAY'S
CONSENT CALENDAR. MOVING TO A
VOTE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ITSELF DOES ANY MEMBER WE'RE
SURE MOVE AN ITEM FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR SEEING HEARING
ON THE CLERK WILL READ THE
SECOND A CONSENT CALENDAR
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE SIXTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO WOMEN IN
CONSTRUCTION WEEK. CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS HAD
A DESIRE TO VOTE. THIS IS THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE. THE CLARK
WELL. CLOSER ALL. HI SEVENTY NO
ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED. THE CLERK WILL READ
THE REMAINING ITEMS ON CONSENT
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE SEVENTY FIVE SEVENTY NO
ZERO SOMETHING CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE SEVENTY SIX FIVE
SEVENTY NO ZERO HOUSE
RESOLUTION SIXTY SIX I SEVENTY
NO ZERO SOMETHING RESOLUTION
ONE SIXTY I SEVENTY O. ZERO AND
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
EIGHTY THREE I SEVENTY. KNOWS
ZERO. MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS
THE SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS FRIDAY MARCH SIX NO
FLOOR SESSION- CHECK IN
SESSION. MONDAY MARCH THE NINTH
FLOOR SESSION IS AT ONE PM. IN
THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION THE
QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED. AND WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED THE GERMANS IN MEMORY
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
WE ARE THE GERMANS IN MEMORY.
AND PLEASE GIVE YOUR RESPECTFUL
ATTENTION TO YOUR COLLEAGUES.
MEMBERS WHERE A GERMAN. OFF OF
THE FLOOR AT THIS TIME.
THE
FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE GRANTED
PRIOR PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON A
GERMAN IN MEMORY. MR HOLDING
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY IN HONOR.
OF A CULTURAL ICON GIO COLOGNE.
IN ADDITION TO BEING A
MARKETING GENIUS A BUSINESSMAN
WHO CARED FOR HIS EMPLOYEES AND
CUSTOMERS AND A VETERAN COLOGNE
IS MOST FAMOUSLY KNOWN FOR
FOUND IN THE GROCERY STORE
CHAIN TRADER JOE'S. HE WAS BORN
ON JUNE THIRD NINETEEN THIRTY
IN SAN DIEGO AND GRADUATED FROM
SAN DIEGO HIGH SCHOOL IN
NINETEEN FORTY SEVEN. AFTER
SPENDING ONE YEAR IN THE
AIRFORCE HE GRADUATED STANFORD
IN NINETEEN FIFTY TWO AND
ENTERED STANFORD BUSINESS
SCHOOL. HE PUT A STANFORD MBA
TO WORK BY LAUNCHING AN
OPERATING GROCERY AND RETAIL
CHAINS IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
THIS INCLUDES PLACES WE KNOW
LIKE THRIFTY DRUG STORE. AND
BIG FIVE SPORTING GOODS. THE
FORTY FIRST DISTRICT IS PROUD
TO BE THE HOME OF THE VERY
FIRST TRADER JOE'S GROCERY
STORE. IT OPENED IN NINETEEN
SIXTY SEVEN IN PASADENA AND IS
STILL THERE. BEYOND THE STORE
TH COLOGNE FAMILY CONTINUES TO
POSITIVELY IMPACT THE COMMUNITY
AS PATRONS OF THE LOS ANGELES
OPERA. THE HUNTINGTON LIBRARY
AND PLANNED PARENTHOOD. COLOGNE
FOUNDED TRADER JOE'S TO SELL
HEALTHY HIGH QUALITY FOOD MORE
AFFORDABLE THAN ANY OTHER STORE.
BUT JONES LEGACY OF JOY AND
ADVENTUROUSNESS TRULY LIVES ON
IN EVERY JAR OF COOKIE BUTTER.
EVERY BOX OF ALMOND WINDMILLS
AND EVERY BOTTLE OF TWO BUCK
CHUCK. THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY HE
WILL BE SORELY MISSED. THANK
YOU MISTER HOLDEN. AND MR CHOW
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GERMAN IN MEMORY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY TO A TURN IN THE MEMORY
OF DOCTOR SUN SO ENDS ON THE
WAY TO THE- BONE IN THAILAND
CHINA DOCTOR SON AND HER FAMILY
RELOCATED TO TAIWAN. WHEN SHE
WAS SIXTEEN A TIRELESS ADVOCATE
FOR QUALITY EDUCATION DOCTOR
SON THAT OPENING OF L'IRAN
KINDERGARTEN AND LEADER AN
INTERNATIONAL PRIVATE IN.
ELEMENTARY AND MIDDLE SCHOOL
NOW CONSIDER ONE OF THE MOST
RENOWNED BILINGUAL EDUCATION
INSTITUTION IN TAIWAN THAT
TEACHES ENGLISH AND CHINESE
LANGUAGES. IN NINETEEN SIXTY
NINE DR SON SIR AS THE COUNCIL
MEMBER FOR TAIPEI CITY. WHERE
SHE CHAMPION INSURANCE AND-
BENEFITS FOR EMPLOYEES IN
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS DR
SUN'S ROLE AS A DEVOTED
DIPLOMAT FOR TAIWAN HAS
ACCORDED. FOR NUMEROUS AND
MEMORABLE EXPERIENCES INCLUDING
AN IMITATION BY PRESIDENT
RICHARD NIXON IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
ARE THE SAMUEL U. S. WHITE
HOUSE SHOWED EDUCATE ISSUE CON.
IN NINETEEN. ASIA TEND THE
CELEBRATION OF TAIPEI. SISTERS
WITH. PAY MAYOR. AND FLUNG YOU.
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY SO DOT SON
WAS INVITED CAL. STATE
SECRETARY ADMIT. OF BEER OF
CIVIL. LEAD THE LEADER IN TO
NOW PRIVACY FOR DANCE. AND
CHORUS IN CULTURAL. IN THE U.
US AND PHILIPPINE. IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY ONE TO GO WAS IN BY
PRESIDENT GOES OF. DOMAIN NAME.
A REPUBLIC PERFORM AND HOPE
RACED FOR CHILDREN'S AT. SINCE
NOT SEVENTY FIVE DR SON HAS DO
FROM ALL THE LEADER IN. PRIVACY
TO PUT UP A FOREIGN CHINESE
CULTURE IN COUNTRIES SUCH AS
JAPAN KOREA PHILIPPINES U. S.
UNITED KINGDOM. SPAIN ARE AND
THE LIGHT DR SUN DEDICATE TIME
TO COMMUNITY SERVICE AND WAS
VERY ACTIVE IN ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING THE ZONTA CLUB.
ROTATE CLUB LISTINGS CLUB
TAIWAN CULTURAL IN H.
ASSOCIATION OF PRIVATE SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION OF CHAU EDUCATION
AND NATIONAL. BASKETBALL
ASSOCIATION WELL WHY AT THE
SITE. PLEASE WILL. IS THE
MISSION JEEZ. AND ACCORDING YOU
PAYING MANNER. DOCTORS SENT
RECEIVED ACT FOR HER CHIEF AND
A WHAT GIVEN BY. DIFFERENT OF
TAIWAN PRESIDENTS JOHN CHIANG
CA PRESIDENCY QUE YEN AND
PRAY D. H. LEE IN TWO THOUSAND
THREE SHE WAS. WITH A TOP X.
EDGE OF TAIWAN PRIVATE CALLED
AND EDUCATION. ROC A BY
PRESIDENT CHEN SAY BIAN. THAT
ARE THE TIE. PRIVACY SO ALL
RECOGNIZE DOCTORS WITH THE HONG
PRY. AND SHE REACHED AN HONOR
DOCTOR DEGREE FOR TALK UNIV.
ADDITIONAL RECKON SINK THE A
AND THE WAR BY TO TRY AMERICA
EDUCATION THE SOCIAL AND SOME
HEALTH. THE WHITE GOAL LIFE
TIME A WHAT BY SELFISH ARMY THE
AMERICAN A TO CON. OF BY THE
QUE SO. MICHAEL ANTONOVICH. AND
IN ALL TO THE FROM THE ROME
CATHOLIC POPE OF THE SIXTEEN
HONORED THAT SCOTT INTO A FEW
OF IT. SOCIAL AND THIS THAT
MINORITY THAT PASSED AWAY WE
CANNOT EVERY TEEN AT IS
SURVIVED BY. CHILDREN AND
ELEVEN GRANDCHILDREN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER. THANK
YOU MISTER SCHECK OUR MEMBERS
IS FREE NAMES TO DESERT IMAGE
ALL. TO RETURN THEM WILL BE
READ PRINTED. JOURNAL ALL OTHER
I REMAINING WILL BE AND RETAIN
ALL MY SHALL BE SEEING HEARING
A FOR THE BIZ SUMMARY ENTER A
MOTION TO ADJOURN MISS. BONTA
MOVE. AND MISTER. SECONDS THAT
THIS HOUSE ADJOURNED UNTIL.
MARCH THE AT ONE PM WE ARE
ADJOURNED.